[Music]
foreign
the two main Titans of the most verse
always change in size every time they
are seen on screen well the question now
is are they going to grow even bigger
but the next time we see them in the GVK
sequel let's take a deep look into their
growth rate growth spurt and all that
jazz
to know the end we must start first from
the beginning as a wise man once said
Godzilla species has been around since
the Permian age around 250 million years
ago but it is unknown if this current
Gojira is that old he only reappeared in
modern times after the nuclear bombing
of Hiroshima and Nagasaki that awaken
one of his Rivals the shinomura gong on
the other hand is a very young Titan by
their standards probably around 100
years old or maybe at the most less than
150. he is an orphan of Skull Island as
his parents were killed by the dreaded
skull Crawlers
as seen in their first own respective
monster verse movies both Titans had
different sizes as compared to their GVK
versions Kong was first seen in the
movie Skull Island and was probably
still hitting puberty back then first
seen chronologically in 1945 when two
pilots crashed landed in Skull Island
Kong was already huge fast forwarding
around 30 years later in the 1970s Kong
was still in his adolescent stage which
might take a long time for Titans and he
was around 104 feet tall or 31.7 meters
Godzilla on the other hand was already
massive and old by the time we saw him
first in 2014. Godzilla was stated to be
355 feet tall or 108 meters and was more
than 850 feet long from head to tip of
the tail
now let's take a look at their sizes and
their respective second appearances and
also in their laws which means in
Godzilla vs Kong Kong was seen again in
the comics though and not in the movies
and he was seen in the birth of gong and
this was set in the late 1990s which
means around 25 years had passed and he
had grown from 104 feet tall to be 270
feet in height or 82 meters and then
finally when Godzilla vs Kong came to be
Kong had finally gotten to his present
size of 337 feet or 103 meters tall
Godzilla in the meantime Grew From 355
feet in 2014 to 393 feet or 120 meters
tall by the time of the king of the
monsters and didn't change a bit in GVK
so there was a massive growth in Kong's
case during that long 50-year period and
a sudden spot of growth for Godzilla
between 2014 and 2019.
so willcom grow even bigger but the next
time we see him well it's highly likely
and there are a few reasons why the
first one is obviously his age even
after growing a big deal from the 1970s
till the 2020s meaning a 50-year growth
spurt growing from 100 feet tall to 337
feet it's a reasonable to think that he
would at least grow a bit more as he
really fully matures
the second reason is that he will now
have access to a larger space and a
hollow Earth to stretch his muscles also
have a good and abundant food source as
well as a change in gravity therefore
altering his muscular and bone density
making him bigger than he was before and
the last reason is his access to the
hollow Earth power source which is the
main reason of accelerating a lot of the
super species growth rates
now will Godzilla grow bigger let's take
a look at why he grew in the first place
well by the time of 2014 Godzilla had
already grown to be a mature animal a
mature super species and while reptiles
do grow until they die the process does
slow down as time passes on he did get a
sudden growth spurt between 2014 and
2019 after his battle with the muto
Prime growing 40 feet taller in a span
of five years but that's about it by the
time of GVK which is set in 2024 which
is still the same five years difference
there was no growth at all this was a
bit confusing did Godzilla finally hit
the limit or does he require something
else for a size to increase like a
near-death experience with the muto
Prime and now against Mechagodzilla so
will he grow again maybe
to know more we have to know their
maximum sizes the calm and Gojira
species we do know that there is a
massive skeleton of a dead Gojira
specimen in the throne room of the Kongs
and this was estimated to be around 500
to 1000 feet tall and while Godzilla is
still half that size his battle against
a bigger Mechagodzilla and quite a time
for a recuperation might again push him
to grow even bigger maybe hitting the
420 to 430 feet Mark in height another
40 feet growth spot after another
near-death battle and as for Kong we do
hope that he will at least be as tall as
Godzilla or even a bit taller and if not
we can be happy with a 122 meters of 400
feet tall giant ape owing to ample space
good food and the power source
and so will the next big enemy be even
bigger than them well that depends on
what kind of Nemesis is waiting for them
both in the next Crisis and having a
smaller arrival will definitely spoil
the fun I bet most of us will bring in a
500 feet tall Destroyer or even space
Godzilla to end the timeline but that's
just our hopes and dreams so I hope you
have enjoyed watching this video do hit
the like button for support and
subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam